Speaker 1: OK, let's hear from a few more people
via discord, you can find The David Pakman Show
discord, David Pakman dotcom discord, very,
very easy to find. Let's go next to Suriya
from New Jersey. Suriya, I hope
I'm pronouncing that correctly.
Speaker 2: Yeah, that's correct. How are
you doing today, David? I'm doing well.
So I recently wrote an article in The Washington
Post that are actually The Washington Post
believe was an opinion piece about vaccines and
vaccine mandates. And basically the gist of that
article was about like to stop creating the anti
vaccine and to just start mandating vaccines.
Speaker 1: So you wrote it or you read it? I
read it. OK, yeah. Max Boot wrote it, right?
Yes. OK, good. Yes, I know the piece.
Speaker 2: Yes. So my question to you is,
when do you think we draw
the line to just like keeping
kind of voluntary vaccination to maybe saying,
OK, well, you might need a vaccine for this
place in this place or maybe this public place.
Speaker 1: So here's a really important thing
that's already being done. There's already 600
schools that have said if you want to be here
as an employee or as a student, you've got to be
vaccinated. There are workplaces that have already
done it. What Max Boot was arguing about and I
talked about that article earlier in the week,
he's saying government mandated vaccination,
where where a state government or any government
would say, you just you have to get a vaccine. And
my view on that is that there is some precedent.
There's a Massachusetts case from 1995 that
says the state could some states could mandate
vaccination. I think it's political suicide. So I
don't I'm not in favor of it, partially because I
think people will still find ways to get around
it, and partially because it would be absolute
and total political suicide. So I just don't see
that. But what you're talking about, which is
schools, businesses, whatever, saying if you want
to work here, if you want to go to school here,
you need a vaccine that's already going on. And
there seems to be no legal issue with it at all.
Speaker 2: OK, yeah, thank
you, that was my question.
Speaker 1: Very good, yeah, good, good. When we
talk about mandatory vaccines, it's sometimes
people say use the term required or use the
term. We're talking about a government blanket
mandate versus a requirement in order to do X. And
these are two very, very, very different things